meine damen und herren wo kommen die
ganzen musiker her wo ist der name der
welt new york rio tokio berlin nein prix
sec und das ist ein ortsteil von klenze
im wendland und dot com massenheer die
gerade ihr neues album wo es beginnt
veröffentlicht haben und das heißt sie
kommen zur klicks und das heißt sie
beantworten eure fragen die er in die
kommentare schreiben können die er als
video frage stellen könnt ihr wissen ins
kommentarfeld klicken und dann daneben
auf den button video antwort klicken und
ansonsten den info text lesen und
kreativ sein das war auch noch ein ganz
nicht unwichtiger bestandteile von einer
frage die dran kommen soll also haut
rein ich bin gespannt madsen auch und
ansonsten bis dann bleib dran